[Musique]
pour
paul moreira bonjour bonjour vous
recevons pour une chaîne youtube qui
s'appelle signe que review voudrais
avoir votre point de vue sur la
géopolitique l'irak l'ukraine et tout ce
qui s'ensuit sur le journalisme
d'investigation
présentez-vous succinctement bas ça fait
25 ans maintenant que je que je suis
journaliste un peu plus et j'ai commencé
par faire du grand reportage par partir
loin ce que je maîtrisais quelques
langues
et puis petit à petit jeu c'est pas
tellement comment les choses se sont
enchaînées mais je me suis retrouvé à
faire ce qu'on appelle du journalisme
d'investigation
j'ai pas tout à fait encore compris ce
que c'était enfin jusqu'où je peux je
n'aime pas la différence entre ce qu'est
le journalisme d'investigation et le
journalisme dit aux journalistes
d'investigation c'est le type qui a le
temps de retourner plus de pierre que le
journaliste que le journaliste
journaliste parce que j'en ai
journalistes et de la rendre son sujet à
midi par exemple
mais au fond on fait le même boulot donc
journaliste woippy bond de plus en plus
j'ai fait des documentaires
ce qui fait appel à savoir faire
différent supplémentaires savoir-faire
narratif qui n'est pas forcément pas
forcément enseigné dans les écoles de
journalisme de 10 ans et donc voilà je
fais des documentaires principalement
des documentaires pour canal+
de temps en temps rareté je sais pas
trop une première ligne j'ai fondé
première ligne en 2006 quand j'ai quitté
canal + si tu veux je te raconte ma bio
donc j'ai été
je passais par capa en télé milieu des
années 90 puis je suis devenu rédacteur
en chef d'une émission qui s'appelait le
vrai journal qui était présenté par
carole 0 c'est déjà longtemps et puis je
suis rentré à canal canal à l'invitation
d'alain de greef qui était le directeur
des programmes à l'époque et j'ai fait
une émission d'enquêtés de reportages
qui s'appelait 90 minutes qui a commencé
en 1999 et qui s'est terminée en 2006 et
qui s'est livré à diverses enquêtes dont
certaines assez tonitruante celle dont
je me souviens avec le plus de
retentissement c'était celle sur le
massacre à l'hôtel ivoire en côte
d'ivoire quand l'armée française avait
ouvert le feu sur des manifestants
désarmés
là le niveau de pression c'est le
pression par qui pas de pression
politique évidemment puisqu'on avait
forcé le ministère de la défense
reconnaître qu'ils avaient fait usage
d'armes létales sur sur des manifestants
notamment 300 je me rappelle c'est 300
munitions explosives sur les ponts de la
lagune
donc après bon canal avait un petit peu
changé d'identité et venez nouveaux gars
qui étaient arrivés les gars de vivendi
ça se passait ça se passait à 10 ans et
avait des conflits des mais il ya un
moment où le niveau de dijon de
déontologie c'est pas vraiment la
déontologie mais c'était tout était fait
tout était fait dans le conflit et c'est
super fatigant de travail dans le
conflit donc voilà je suis parti tout en
continuant à bosser pour pour canal+
mais j'ai fondé ma boîte que j'ai fondé
une boîte indépendante avec les valeurs
qui sont les miennes endroit
c'est-à-dire essayé essayé essayé de
s'approcher de quelque chose de
difficile à attraper qui s'appelle la
vérité et essayer de ne pas être
prisonniers des stéréotypes des discours
dominants et y compris de ses propres de
ses propres préjugés ça c'est le plus
dur est donc d'avoir un peu un oeil à
9,9 fraises sur les sujets qu'on aborde
donc cash investigations par première
ligne c'est ça cache investigations ça
arrive donc à quatre ans ça arrive c'est
une conception de conjonction
d'événements et à des gens qui nous
rejoignent de capa laurent richard jean
pierre canet
qui pareille appartenait pas la même
culture canal etc
elise à qui la direction élise lucet à
qui la direction de france 2 confie
magazine d'investigation économique
et voilà c'était un peu naturel on se
connaissait depuis longtemps parce qu'on
est un peu le même boulot on se
respectait on sait mais bien on aimait
bien les trajectoires suivies elles
elles voulaient faire quelque chose de
sur le plan narratif de beaucoup plus
libre de beaucoup plus ouvert de
beaucoup plus de moins corsetées de ce
que ce qu'on avait fait jusqu alors nous
aussi ça tombait bien
et voilà est né cache investigations qui
a tout de suite rencontré un intérêt du
public et de l'estiment l'estiment des
confrères ce qui est très important
quand on fait ce genre de boulot parce
que l'investigation c'est ils ont un
terrain sur lequel on se crée beaucoup
d'inimitiés s'en prend souvent à des
gens qui canton quand ils vous aiment
pas les moyens de 21,2 ou nous faire
taire ou de vous ennuyer
considérablement
on reviendra sur la partie
journalistique la création
journalistique un peu plus tard vous
revenez d'irak et combien de temps vous
est revenue vous être une semaine une
semaine
qu'est-ce que vous avez été faire là bas
d'abord c'est la sixième fois que je
vais en irak
la première fois que j'y vais c'est en
avril 2003 je me rappelle j'ai le
dernier vise à saddam le visage du
gouvernement saddam donné par le
l'ambassade à paris je le kiffe
précieusement je suis rentré dans bagdad
le jour de sa chute officielle le 9
avril 2003 et en fait ça a beaucoup à
voir avec 7
cette régularité dans mes voyages en
irak ce que j'allais faire ce que en
fait j'allais raconter des ch comment
dèche a totalement remodelé le
moyen-orient principalement l'irak et la
syrie
mais je voulais raconter au lieu de le
raconter à travers l'expertisé et de
l'investigation traditionnel disons je
voulais raconter à travers le regard de
mes yeux copains parce que évidemment
quand on va sur 15 ans comme ça sur un
pays on retrouve un peu toujours les
mêmes genres des gens qu'on a tourné des
gens qu'on a suivi et c'était important
pour moi de voir en quoi cette guerre
les avait changé comment il voyait
l'avènement de dèche
enfin la relecture de commandes s était
arrivé à quoi c'était dû donc c'est
assez
sur le plan géopolitique c'est les
racines de dèche et sur le plan narratif
ça serait d'ailleurs racontée par mes
vieux potes qu'ils ont quelle vision il
en quelle perception sur les forces
américaines sur le les racines même la
naissance du conflit en irak
est ce que les armes de destruction
massive ils les ont trouvés c'est que on
sait qui avait pas d'armes de
destruction massive a même georgetown
yeux bouche bien ennuyé dit bah ouais on
croyait qu'un navet on s'est fait avoir
par une information qui était pas de
bonne qualité
vous avez vous avez creusé cette
information de potes bonne qualité
aujourd'hui à tout est à peu près connu
acer que celles des réseaux
néoconservateurs qui faisait beaucoup la
promotion d'un certain ahmed chalabi qui
a beaucoup beaucoup qui est mort
maintenant 2
deux maladies qui a beaucoup en fumée
les américains les néocons se sont
emparés 10 ans de ces deux cette
doctrine
ouais en fait c'est une sorte de
prétextes quoi c'était au texte pourquoi
donc pour envahir l'irak
en fait c'est assez marrant parce que il
ya une lettre qu'il est tracée célèbre
qu'elvis il trouver maintenant mais
c'est là la lettre du programme for a
new american century le problème voilà
le pn assez le programme pour une
nouveau siècle américain qui est une
sorte de une sorte de film tant qu'une
sorte de deux groupes d' influence des
néo conservateurs dans le département
d'état américain
en dedans il ya vols chauds vite
rossfeld tout le gang qui va qui va qui
va prendre les manettes à partir à
partir de 2000 et c'est une bêtise
envoie en 98 clinton en expliquant qu'il
faut renverser saddam hussein pour
défendre les intérêts économiques des
états unis dans la région et de ses
alliés c'est très très intéressant parce
que c'est une lettre qui sait que comme
dans le gard powell il n'y a pas de
conspiration puisque la lettre la lettre
et public elle est connue de tous et
c'est une lettre qui en fait donne un
peu le blanc seing ouais pas la feuille
de route de pourquoi il faut agir en
irak et à aucun moment le mot démocratie
ou apporter la démocratie aux irakiens
né citer aucun moment donc c'est assez
c'est assez éclairant est assez amusant
sur comment en fait ce grand pays que
les etats unis c'est avec ces mécanismes
de transparence est assez rare qu'ils
arrivent à garder une information
dissimulés très très longtemps quoi
c'est souvent les intentions sont assez
assez clair et assez assez transparente
elle a été le cas et donc effectivement
en 2001 après après qu'oussama ben laden
et al-qaïda et mis deux avions dans les
tours et un dans le pentagone
il ya un lien dans la manche en
championnat on va celui là c'était des
gens là je crois que c'était la
résistance des passagers qui a fait
qu'il se soit retrouvé dans un champ
mais là c'est en fait si l'on profitez
donc de cette de cette immense émotion
pour appliquer le concept de la guerre
préventive donc dire il ya des armes de
destruction massive en irak
on va y aller on va rentrer et on va les
trouver et on va anéantir le risque
avant avant qu'ils aient avant qu'il
existe et c'est ce qui a été fait donc
ça serait les irakiens sur place vos
potes ils en sont où là ils ont quelle
perception quand ils voient des hummer
quand ils voient des ch quand ils voient
alors pour eux parce que bon travail
survivre comment d'abord il faut savoir
que eux ils ont forcément une vision
conspirationnistes par définition c'est
quoi une fusion conspiration redan fc
les états unis pourquoi c'est la main
des états unis parce que avant il avait
un pays et maintenant ils en ont plus et
là là là au bout de quinze enfin les
américains sont partis de terre mais ce
qui reste sur place et qui fait que le
pays ait brisé en trois en l'occurrence
pascal kurdistan cédait ch
donc il cherche toujours une explication
raisonnable rationnelle enfin ils ont vu
des tanks en vrai métal
arrivé chez eux tirer un peu à gauche à
droite puisque les américains ont cette
capacité à utiliser la puissance de feu
de manière parfois un peu excessive on
va dire donc pour eux c'est une sorte de
plan qui continue ce qui est évidemment
faux
mais ce qui dans leur dans leur ticket
s'explique s'explique parfaitement qui
voit arriver des types ils vont arriver
180000 gars qui disent chercher des
armes de destruction massive qui
n'existe pas qui plus ou moins pense
qu'ils ont tout à voir avec les les
attentats de septembre 2001
donc ils se disent ben voilà l'histoire
continue ils ont inventé encore un
prétexte bidon
pour péter notre pays ça je le fais
vraiment rapide et en simple parce qu'en
fait ce qui s'est passé depuis 15 ans
c'est un truc d'une tragédie de
dimension phénoménale puisque on sait
pas exactement combien de gens sont
morts mais c'est le million à les
estimations les plus faibles donnent
sept cent mille et les estimations les
plus fortes mais je pense qu'elles sont
fausses donne 2 millions en fait on n'a
jamais réussi à compter parce qu'à
l'époque où ça où il y avait le plus de
morts en 2006 n'avait pas envoyé un
statisticien d'académie ou dans cedar
city pour recompter les mortes parce
qu'il en serait parvenu quoi donc c'est
des évaluations mais en tout cas des
centaines de milliers de morts ça ça on
en est sûr est un pays clé parce que la
base la racine de dèche
c'est le conflit ce qu'ils appellent le
conflit sectaire sert le conflit
interconfessionnel entre les sunnites et
les chiites
c'est là que naît dèche c'est dans le
fait que ces deux communautés qui se
sont jamais trop aimé qu'ils vivaient
ensemble qu'ils partageaient un pays qui
s'entretuent et pas qui quand les choses
allaient bien il y avait un peu
d'internât riaj enfin ça vivait ensemble
quoi après l'arrivée des américains
il commence à y avoir les premières
scission à l'intérieur d'eux
de la communauté irakienne au départ les
américains tentent de tente de nous
concentrer sur arc à huy qui est le
fondateur de l'état islamique de dèche
tente de consac que de concentrer sur
darkaoui le à la fois les peurs les
haines les ressentiments de des irakiens
en lui mettant sur le dos la plupart des
actes de résistance
sauf que cette cette logique là c'est un
peu c'est un peu la logique du de
l'apprenti sorcier c'est à dire que
c'est rationnel de faire ça sauf que ça
va déraper dans un truc assez violent
rapidement au bout d'un an ou dû créer
une sorte de réactions xénophobes contre
les combattants étrangers de ce qui
n'était pas encore des choses qui
s'appelait à l'époque je croyais qaïda
en irak
en vérité ça comme al qaïda en irak 20
répliques et enfin va va frapper de
manière extrêmement violente la
communauté chiite
ça va créer une âgisme extrêmement
violent qui va donner lieu à une guerre
interconfessionnelle d'une violence
extraordinaire
je me rappelle l'avoir été en 2006 et
s'était c'était vraiment vraiment
vraiment incroyable quoi sert y avait
des combats en plein milieu de la ville
je me rappelle d'un daim
d'autres guerre entre chiites et
sunnites je me rappelle d'une prise
d'otage géante au ministère de lave de
l'éducation supérieure 170 personnes qui
ont été prises en otage en plein jour
dans un car à d'astrid qui est
l'équivalent de la rue de rivoli
23 voitures aux 30 33 voitures qui sont
arrivés ils ont pris les gens en otage
on les a jamais retrouvé 170 personnes
les américains qui étaient en cours une
force occupante à ce moment là avait
beaucoup de mal à expliquer ce qui
s'était passé il est oui c'est les
terroristes am il avait des uniformes de
police ah non mais c'est parce qu'ils
ont acheté aux puces un énorme et il on
avait des voitures de police
hommes et ils ont dû maquiller des
voitures mais l'été c'est pas ça qui
s'est passé c'est qu'il ya des membres
de milices chiites qui ont attaqué un
ministère sous contrôle sunnite et qui
ont pris en otage 170 personnes et dans
les jours qui ont suivi il y avait des
combats entre les quartiers chics des
quartiers sunnites en plein milieu de la
ville des combats dont très peu de monde
parlait parce qu'on pouvait pas sortir
on pouvait pas en entendait on entendait
des tirs a parfois 100 mètres de l'hôtel
mais sortir était impossible le niveau
de danger est tel qu'au fond tout ça est
resté dans une opacité dans une opacité
absolue est donc maintenant les irakiens
sur place ils en sont où l'éducation les
gamins les déchets radioactifs cause de
l'uranium appauvri les naissances avec
les bébés complètement difformes
ouais ça c'est à falloudja à falloudja à
falloudja est aux mains de l'état
islamique
plus pour longtemps à mon avis
[Musique]
il vient une sorte de normalité à bagdad
qui est revenu dans la ville même donc
c'est vrai que quand on quand on est à
bagdad on se dit bon bah ça va quoi
femme moi je manger en terrasse le soir
dîner en terrasse je me baladais dans la
rue la nuit ça n'est pas arrivé depuis
longtemps donc on se dit bon il ya
quelque chose qui fonctionne quoi
c'était le ramadan les gens étaient
dehors c'est assez et puis et puis et
des attentats à l'explosif boom 30
personnes tuées et 70 blessées graves
et puis elle fait que la ville les
lignes de vie de la ville sont brisés
l'approvisionnement se passe comme
l'approvisionnement il se passe par le
par le kurdistan
tu manges et commenté par l'iran tu
mangeais coin terrasse bon bah tu mens
je débranche est comme d'habitude les
quais bas de poulet ou de mouton c'est
toujours un peu le même truc mais ça
c'était vrai avant l'avant les carpes
aussi pêche des cartes en retire et les
fonds au barbecue c'est très bon et mais
c'est incroyable ce dire tu es dans une
ville imagine pas ri té dans paris la
vierre à peu près normale et à partir de
melun tous les ponts des autoroutes sont
brisés et donc celles à l'autoroute est
impraticable donc tu peux plus aller ni
vers le sud ni vers l'ouest en
l'occurrence eux ne peuvent pas la seule
ligne de vie qui leur reste il est à
l'iran mais là le l'autoroute vers la
jordanie vers l'ouest elle et elle est
brisée parce qu'elle est dans le seeland
elle est contrôlée par contre les parts
des ch et même quand des chats
contrôlera plus et donc pour des mois
avant de avant 2 avant de nettoyer les
gravats les pour écrouler les dominos en
fait ça c'est un effet inattendu mais ça
ça s'arrache et avec l'iran voilà
exactement au fond si tu devais si tu
devais résumer d'une phrase 15 ans de
guerre c'est l'iran aa a accru son
territoire jusqu'à en gros jusqu'à
flütsch c'est un peu brutale de dire ça
enfin quand tu que je n'ai pas croisé
mais j'ai vu des photos
le chef des services secrets iraniens le
général souleymane sy qui vient tout
souriant sur le champ de bataille où on
en est de l'offensive contre des shu
c'est quand même c'est extraordinaire
quoi c'est ça c'est une des conséquences
inattendues de la guerre des américains
en irak
c'est moi souvent quand j'ai quand je
parle de cette opération j'appelle ça
l'opération rantanplan parce que c'était
quand même le retrait mlle rémy l'iran à
l'époque
or ils ont offert un pays avec des
ressources pétrolières l'infini à
l'heure et demie de l'époque ils ont
renforcé énormément le la puissance de
l'iran
les journalistes d'investigation sur
place sans croiser un petit poucet ils
sont tous cachés dans les graviers tel
dans étrangers irakien aussi étrangers y
en a ils font ils font leurs reportages
depuis leur toilette
nous menons maintenant et sortent avant
ils s'en sortent ouais j'ai maintenant
surtout ce nom le moment où il y avait
plus grand monde qui sortais c'était
2006 là c'était compliqué il ya qui sur
place la voir maintenant quelle est
l'origine les russes je n'ai pas vu mais
il doit y en avoir
je sais qu rocha today diffusée truc
j'ai vu beaucoup de journalistes
irakiens
et puis avait il y avait des français
des américains et des anglais
c'est ce que j'ai vu mais tout le monde
hier et je me sors les journalistes ont
ciblé la va parce que c'est une cible de
choix pour soi la monnayer
ou est ce que c'est une cible de choix
parce que les irakiens suspecte des
injections de services de renseignement
ou via les journalistes pour les
irakiens ils sont un peu parano donc
quelques raisons de l'être mais c'est
vrai qu'il te rendent la vie très très
compliqué hein quand tu es journaliste
cible de choix
il est clair que si tu es dans une zone
de combat avec un sniper de dèche
quelles lunettes en bon état de
fonctionnement entre un mec qui a une
kalach est un mec qu'une caméra il va
pas hésiter il va tirer sur la mecque
qu'à la caméra déjà eu pas mal de deux
journalistes irakiens en l'occurrence
qui ont été tués pendant l'offensive de
falloudja donc la caméra toujours le
problème toujours le problème est dans
ce pays il ya une sensibilité à l'image
qui est assez pénible en fait quand tu
vois parce que quand tu fais de la
presse écrite sava témoin témoin de tenu
à ramener des images mais quand tu fais
de la télé c'est super pénible tout cas
sans arrêt justifier ton identité dash
pas par pur gouvernement irakien ou aux
groupes armés qui s'appelle hd le chaâbi
qui sont les brigades populaire qui
combattent des shs donc et tout le temps
obligé de justifier de son identité quoi
aussi il faut dire que tu vois quand
anne attentats de dèche par exemple dans
la dans les quatre cinq minutes qui
suivent une revendication sur twitter
avec une image donc ça veut dire que tu
avais un mec de dèche sur place café une
image avec son téléphone portable qui
l'a immédiatement twitté en revendiquant
l'attentât
parce que quand tu arrives sur un
attentat parmi les mecs qui t'entourent
tu as un deux trois personnages qui sont
liées à l'état islamique c'est un peu
c'est un peu stressant c'est un peu
stressant c'est un peu stressant aussi
parce que tu allais d'aller double
attentat ça c'est le truc le plus
stressant avec les services de soins et
qui débarque et serpette voilà ça c'est
vraiment très stressant petit classique
et qu'est ce que tu penses de jeu si mes
souvenirs sont moyens un journaliste
anglais qui s'est infiltrée dans les
réseaux islamiques et qui a fait un
reportage de l'intérieur sur les réseaux
islamiques tu veux parler de djalma
quand il a le nez qui sert kiss qui
tiennent micro à l'état islamique je
crois mais un rat cas je crois bien
ouais alors alors c'est non je parle pas
de celui-là
ouais ça c'est c'est un mec qui était
soi disant sous pression qui a fait un
reportage qui était prisonnier
métaphorisation qui veut survivre
l'exacte euros je parle pas du ps je
parle d'un autre excuse moi j'ai
complètement oublié son nom
tu parles d'un palestinien qui a fait un
truc pour vice news exactement
ouais bien vu ah j'oubliais son nom mais
écoute je l' ai vu évidemment je les ai
vus c'était le premier film qui a été
tourné sur sur l'état islamique à
l'intérieur bon c'est infime autorisé
comme salafistes le film gags qu'on fait
mario la lmc intéressant évidemment
intéressante à tellement peu d'image de
l'état islamique que n'importe quoi est
intéressant même quelque chose qui
contraint même quelque chose qui
tournait sous contrôle
c'est on prend ce qu'on à quoi donc
c'est moi ça va ça m'a vraiment
intéressé bleus voir ceci dit je tu vois
je voyais bien qu'il avait un il y avait
un guide qui le suivait qui lorientais
mais ils ont fait le job quelque part va
il se trouve puisque quand les types
disait je me rappelle est rentré dans un
tribunal islamique al maqdisi normes et
les chrétiens sont les bienvenus sur le
territoire de l'état islamique
il suffit qu'ils paient d'impôts etc et
il y avait immédiatement dans le sujet
un contrepoint qui expliquait qu'en fait
les chrétiens dans les zones dans les
zones du nord du sinjar avaient été ou
massacrés ou obligés de quitter leur
maison
donc c'était c'est du journalisme au
sens où tu prends pas ce que le mec tu
dis pour combattre déclaration pour de
la vérité pour une vérité maintenant
idéalement ce qu'il faut faire avec eux
c'est de les infiltrer avec une caméra
cachée mais ya très très peu de monde
qui est capable de le faire ce que c'est
très très très dangereux
qu'est ce tu penses des attentats de
paris ce que je pense des attentats
d'écouté y en a un qui s'est déroulée
sur mon palier puisque je suis voisins
de charlie hebdo
je pense qu'un imbécile avec une
kalachnikov et à l'école quand même un
type dangereux quoi que je déduction est
ce que c'est une répercussion d'une
politique guerrière complètement
mégalomane qui vient il rit radiés ou
irradié sur notre propre territoire
je pense que c'est plus profond que ça
je pense que pour mettre un tout petit
peu intéressée à djihadisme hexagonal
c'est quoi le djihadisme à l'ailé mais
les gamins séduit par des ch qui rêvent
de mourir qui rêve d'aller au paradis
ces mecs sont obsédés par l'idée d'aller
au paradis ils sont être obsédé de se
trouver un chemin pour leur vie ouais
non mais ce que ce que je veux dire
c'est pour ça que je dis c'est à dire
que c'est difficile de réduire ça à des
données géopolitiques il ya une donnée
géopolitique évidemment lu mes gueux
l'état islamique d'irak a sont ravis de
pouvoir semer le chaos ici de pouvoir
attaquer la france en son coeur mais le
le fait que août en deux
autant vous pas exagérer je pense que
prêt à passer à l'action il doit y avoir
deux cents 200 200 types à la tête cramé
en france qui sont capables je te le
fais au doigt mouillé âge cinquième
colonne non c'est pas une cinquième
colonne cc2 sans peau mais quand tu
regardes les bios des mecs qui sont qui
sont morts au bataclan
c'est quand même des fracas c'est
monstrueux quoi c'est des ratés du
banditisme d'abord c'est des mecs ont
raté leur carrière de ben 10 sakho de
force coulibaly il a passé plus de temps
en prison que dehors quand tu regardes
ces hold up c'est des trucs minable quoi
il a si ce fait décidé à son meilleur
copain est mort pour une histoire de
mobylettes voler ou de motos volées dans
un magasin passé et puis fait de la
prison ils essayent de faire parler de
lui il essaie de faire parler de ce qui
se passe avec l'uriné registre assez
c'est un type qui en gros complètement
raté sa vie et est brusquement le l'état
islamique l'allégeance à l'état
islamique lui donne la visibilité la
légitimité
là la force pose comment il devient un
type énorme
et puis il ya l'idée que au paradis
c'est vraiment un truc très prenant dans
leur tête quoi c'est qu'au paradis
quelque chose de formidable les attend
mais ange ayora cube la jouissance que
de l'apec de la sérénité que voilà et
dont tu vois que ces mecs là c'est
vraiment les soldates pied d'une
idéologie d'ailleurs c'est souvent c'est
marrant parce que quand on parle d'islam
à leur égard la plupart du temps ils
n'ont pas la tête retournée par le coran
et dans la tête retournée par des films
conspirationnistes qu'ils ont vu sur sur
internet s'est dans certains cas c'est
qu'à moitié des trucs islamique quoi
donc c'est assez peu l'autre moitié
l'autre moitié dans un film que j'ai vu
récemment ses fils conspirationnistes
sur un truc qui s'appelait soldats
d'allah sur sur canal plus et c'était un
film conspirationnistes fabriqués par
des télévangélistes
c'était d'extrême droite américains pour
les manipuler pour les manipuler eu
précisément non je crois pas non non non
ce des trucs comme temps à dessein des
centaines sur internet qui te disent tu
vois la vérité n'est pas là c'est
ailleurs machin il ya un complot au
choix illuminati judéo bidule et à eux
ça leur donne ça leur donne évidemment
une armature en quelque sorte
mais au fond le terrorisme
2 j'ai du mal utilisé le mot terroriste
quand je parle d'eux parce que le mot
terroriste a été utilisé pour désigner
des résistants pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale donc si j'ai toujours du mal à
dire terroriste majid préfère dire des
assassins comme lala les raisons qu'ils
ont d'assassiner elles sont aussi fortes
que les raisons qu'ils ont de mourir l'
envie de nourrir faire envie de tuer
chez eux elle est aussi forte voire
peut-être même inférieur alors envie de
mourir c'est un transfert de l' envie de
vivre peut-être non peut-être qu est ce
que tu penses de de la politique de
l'état français concernant la gestion de
ce problème là l'état d'urgence la
gestion des conflits toi en tant que
journaliste en tant que reporter de
guerre
quand tu vois le conflit s'exporter ce
terrorisme hors sol à vrai dire
keystone ta ta ta vision des choses à ce
que l'état d'urgence est ce que quand
monique et annonce il ya quatre cinq
jours que il ya des menaces sur
bruxelles et paris avec l'antériorité
des prédictions de monique et qu'est ce
t'en penses et ensuite je te donnerai un
papier je te demanderai de le lire sans
dire ce qu'il ya dessus et nous on a
cette information depuis 20 jours
je t'en prie vas-y non un coup dessus
enfin moi je connais pas la qualité des
informations qui ont fuité
je sais ce que je sais c'est que les
flics écoute beaucoup de monde c'est
quoi beaucoup beaucoup enfin c'est que
il affiche est ce de manière très large
et qu' ils écoutent ils tracent
énormément de monde dans l'est dans les
milieux islamistes d'ailleurs c'est pour
ça qu'il advint 10% des mecs qui ont
commis des attentats en france était
connu des services de police est fiché
et pour certains écouter le dernier lac
à tuer le couple de policiers habilités
écouter en permanence et c'est le cas
quasiment pour tout ça le problème c'est
que les mecs ça faire il le downgrade
technologique pardon c'est du dong raid
technologique
ben en fait je sais pas ce que tu veux
dire par là mais c'est simple comme le
hamas utilise des pigeons pour envoyer
des petits messages courts alors on
résume si un trivial mans ouais mais eux
c'est beaucoup plus à offrir que tu rien
qu'avec une carte sim lycos est un faux
nom tu peux ouvrir une mine
tu peux yvelines identifiables par les
flics c'est les dealers utilise ça faut
dire que c'est un peu la même population
c'est petite délinquance deezer etc
qu'ils vont ils vont garder les mêmes
les mêmes pratiques du présidium pardon
tu connais des dealers au genre inconnu
ouais là maintenant je connais pas tu
cherchais quelque chose non ça je te
passe un papier
et puis je te compte je te pose une
petite question
alors on reçoit on a pris 100 m on fait
comme à la nsa new way on fait comme
aline et ça se lit non te lis pas je lis
pour moi je voi pa watts
nous on a ça depuis 20 jours tous tes
lunettes écoute j'y arrive
miraculeusement 20 jours ouais tu plies
tu me saoules les fesses et peut-être
que je te donnerai le truc sont le noir
as tu l'as en noir et bien oui
[Musique]
donc je voudrais savoir maintenant si à
tes yeux l'état français nous protège
réellement
écoute de mon expérience microscopique
parce que je suis pas un spécialiste des
services
ils font ce qu'ils peuvent quoi ils font
ce qu'ils peuvent ils ont arrêté des
trucs quand même je pense que ils ont
pas les moyens
tu vois en fait moi je suis convaincue
d'un truc c'est que on ne peut vaincre
dans cette guerre parce que c'est quand
même une guerre qu avec des moyens
humains
certes c'est bien d'écouter les gens
étaient rasées nécessaire mais où font
les derniers attentats qui ont été
commis on a bien vu que la mecque
discuter de la pluie et du beau temps et
qu'il avait un canal de communication
qui les a rendus inidentifiable donc la
seule vraie méthode pour essayer de
savoir ce qui se passe c'est d'infiltrer
des gens et avance un vrai gentil et
avant ça parce qu'un filtre et c'est
simplement une on va dire c'est un
symptôme mais mais pour essayer de
dialoguer essayer d'apaiser les choses à
ce que tu vois une amie dans més les
cotations mais bien sûr et à 2 il ya
deux niveaux il ya essayé mais il faut
il faut faciliter l'intégration il faut
que la discrimination soit un peu moins
violente dans ce pays où c'est
impossible d'avoir un boulot et un
logement quand on s'appelle ahmed ben
machin et tout ça je pense qu'on est on
est d'accord là dessus mais il ya une
urgence koren serre que moi je suis à la
fois il ya un hémisphère de mon cerveau
qui est absolument convaincu que
fondamentalement il faut injecter plus
de plus de 10 mai plus de plus de plus
de liberté aussi plus d'égalité un
fonctionnement un peu moins
discriminatoire dans cette société qui a
produit dans ces banlieues dose de
désespoir et d'amertume qui a nourri le
passage le passage à l'acte de la
seconde de mecs mais ça c'est sur le
long terme mais sur le court terme
je crois même pour une des premières
fois de la vie ces cons je suis
convaincu qu'il faut il faut leur faire
la guerre quoi il faut le dire a
violemment violemment violemment c'est à
dire y aller comme les américains n'ont
pas y aller comme les américains non non
non lagacé imbécilement parce qu'ils
n'ont pas réussi ils ont réussi à rien
mais faut larguer faut faire la guerre
violemment ça veut dire il faut être
présent
dans ces réseaux là et il faut il faut
en fait mettre les gens en taule
inventis alors qu'il passe à l'acte quoi
toi s'il y avait eu quelqu'un dans le
temps à molenbeek auprès d'abdessalam
avant qu'il rentre au bataclan
ça aurait été quand même beaucoup plus
agréable pour un ensemble de gens qu'ils
aient pu être arrêté par un coup de
filet avant le passage à l'acte qu' il
ait le temps de se faire mourir pendant
quoi ça a été quand même du point de vue
et des gens qui sont morts et des
familles beaucoup plus beaucoup mieux le
financement de l'état islamique le
financement d'isis le financement avec
kaita les réseaux on va dire la vision
conspirationnistes de l'égyptien c'est
celui qui dit voile à al qaïda au départ
c'est financé par les etats unis c'est
au départ les talibans financé par les
etats unis c'est le chien qui se
retourne pour mordre la main de son
maître que tu penses de cette vision là
oui c'est un petit raccourci puisque les
talibans en tant que tel n'existait pas
dans les années 80 quand en gros la
doctrine brésil ce qui a commencé à
s'appliquer
tu sais moi j'ai fait l'interview d'un
type vraiment intéressant qui s'appelle
milton bearden qui était le responsable
cia de l'opération afghanistan gros
bonhomme centurions de la cia et j'ai
fait son interview quinze jours après le
11 septembre 2001 on avait fait donc
pour 90 minutes émission dont je m'en
occupais dont je m'occupais une enquête
qui s'appelait islamistes usa les
liaisons dangereuses
on n'imagine pas à quel point
l'anticommunisme hystérique de reggane
et auparavant l'anticommunisme
hystérique quand même de carter de fait
qui passe pour un bon gars mais la
doctrine président ce qui elle commence
avec carter on n'imagine pas le dégâts
que ça a eu sur cette planète
c'est un quantifiable mais et surtout
sur les haies les américains le par
exemple on l'avait raconté l'histoire
d'un mec fascinant que ses plaies ali
mohamed qui était un égyptien mec de
l'armée égyptienne mais qui était en
fait un type de ja matelas et ce ne sera
jamais le strauss à bâle seigneur je
vois mal alyssa milano sera n'existait
pas à l'époque jamaa islamiya d'enquêté
le était l'ancêtre d'al qaïda en egypte
et le mec avait d'excellents rapports
avec al-qaïda et réussi dans les années
80 enfin 80 88 à aller aux états unis a
intégré l'armée américaine à devenir à
fort bragg le spécialiste le spécialiste
de l'islamisme des pays musulmans a
donné des cours des séminaires devant
dégradé et c est le type était un des
bras droit de ben laden
il va organiser les attentats contre les
ambassades de dar es salaam ambassades
américaines de dar es salaam est aidée
nairobi et seulement après ces attentats
en 98 parce que la beauté du truc c'est
que les services secrets américains ont
toujours su qu'il était en contact avec
avec ben laden est le mec fuselage en
double mais l'agent double sens jamais
dissimulé qu'il était islamistes parce
qu'à un moment donné on avait interviewé
son supérieur rh et qui disait mais mais
pour nous c'était pas un problème que ce
soit fondamentalisme musulman fonda miss
fondamentalistes musulmans parce qu'anne
à une époque c'était des alliés la donne
et anti communiste était tellement
hystérique que ouais ils se sont alliés
avec des gens qui étaient qui étaient
des fondamentalistes musulmans qui ont
joué
mais pas seulement en afghanistan en
egypte aussi ont joué le rôle de
supplétif dans la destruction de la
gauche de la gauche ou communistes ou
laïcs dans le cadre dans le cas de
l'egypte et oui c'est un secret pour
personne mais le la situation qu'on vit
aujourd'hui est en grande partie
imputable aux 3 milliards de dollars que
les américains vont injecter dans la
création de groupes armés islamistes
pour emmerder les russes et les pro
russes en afghanistan allait forcément
ben laden à l'époque place j'aime me
faire assassiner par la communauté parce
qu'ils vont vouloir qu'on continue le
sujet de l'irak
je voudrais qu'on passe à autre chose
l'ukraine tu as fait un reportage sur le
créneau est chez vilipendé un peu par
une partie de excuse moi parler comme ça
mais une partita caste une caste bas la
caste journalistique
ah oui ouais ouais
comment ça s'est passé comment tu es
parti là bas qu'est ce que tu as vu
qu'elles sont allées télé alors
l'ukraine moi c'est un endroit que je ne
sais pas du tout et en fait moi ce qui
me fascine dans ce métier est pourquoi
je le fais c'est l'histoire de
perception je suis toujours
j'ai toujours très intéressé de voir
comment les perceptions se construisent
parce que je pense que c'est ça
aujourd'hui la définition de la
propagande c'est la guerre de la
perception et dans le cas de l'ukraine
encore une fois que je ne connaissais
pas du tout que je n'avais pas où
j'étais pas aller c'est un peu en
vagabond d'oran sur internet comme on le
fait tous comme ça
que je tombe sur une histoire qu'ils
massacrent d'odessa avec les snipers non
non tu vois là mais toi tu sais pas ce
que c'est mais 2 mai 2004 il ya 46
cependant personnes qui ont été brûlées
vives par des milices d'extrême droite
pas pro russe pru craignaient avec
personne le savez c'est là où il ya eu
la femme enceinte avec le fils de
téléphone autour de la gorge ouais alors
ça c'est un décès une photo on s'est pas
enfin la blesser la c7 ces images d'un
de là et si tu veux moi je suis
journaliste d'investigation comme on dit
et je tombe sur un massacre en plein
milieu de l'europe qui c'est qu'a eu
lieu la et j'en ai pas entendu parler ça
me rappelle vaguement un truc tu vois là
on est vraiment dans la perception je me
dis ça me rappelle vaguement un truc
mais j'étais convaincu que c'était
l'autre bord que c'était pro russe qui
avait tué des ukrainiens toi dans ma
tête comme ça de ce qui reste de
l'histoire c'est vraiment laid qu'une la
perception comme toi je suis pas un
spécialiste mais donc je m'adresse
autour de moi à d'autres copains
journalistes et au dessin ça dit quelque
chose et personne ne savait rien dit oui
il y avait un truc un espèce de flou qui
m'a fasciné en fait et j'ai commencé à
creuser
et là je découvre un truc hallucinant
quand j'ai j'avais jamais vu ça de ma
vie c'est des heures d'image je crois
que c'est la première fois qu'il ya un
pogrom qui est filmé c'est marrant j'ai
monté avec un copain le monteur est un
copain israéliens et digitas j'imaginais
pas qu'un jour de mode de ma vie je
verrai un pogrom un programme en train
de se réaliser ou d'aujourd'hui perdre
la tête
alors deux deviennent fous et et tout
mais plus ça va plus je me fait happer
par ces images qu'ils soient des images
d'une violence extraordinaire je me dis
mais comment on en a pas parlé et je
commence à regarder
je me dis non mais ça n'a pas été
censurée juste on l'a évoqué doucement
ça n'a pas été approfondi il n'y a pas
eu de protestation des chancelleries
paris a eu ya pas eu d enquête du
gouvernement ukrainien il n'y a pas et
il n'y a pas eu de forensic de gens qui
sont allés sur place gratter des
éléments terrain et là je commence à
bien me seatelli haut on est en plein
coeur du 21e siècle truc à 2h d'image
là-dessus et il n'y a quasiment rien
dans les médias ou pire que rien parce
qu'encore quand un truc est censuré tu
peux dire à censurer la tup là tu fus
décoller l'info non là c'est filandreux
quoi c'est à peine évoqués pas traiter
pas traiter pas vraiment traiter ces
autres donc toi tu débarques là dedans
et donc je me dis c'est facile c'est il
se passe un truc est donc là je découvre
qu'en fait les méchants du film dansé
dans cette configuration là sont sont
précisément les victimes vers les pro
russe et russophone mais quel que soit
le nom qu'on leur donne et là en fait ce
que je petit à petit ce que je remonte
c'est que on a une sorte de rigidité
dans la perception de la perception de
ce qui s'est passé en ukraine
on a donné un chapeau blanc et un
chapeau noir ou deux camps sans chercher
à être un peu complexe quoi d'ordre dans
ce qui s'était passé et je découvre or
j'avais entrevue quand je voyais les jt
pendant le pas en mai d'âne je voyais
des images 2d image un peu bizarre de
mecs avec des avec des symboles un peu
bizarre je me suis mis c'est qui ces
mecs là et c'était à mon sens pas
suffisamment traité quoi et donc je
découvre qu'il ya azor travis hector
donc en gros des milices dont les
les gens sont historiquement
appartiennent à des groupes néo nazis
enfin est-il passé
c'est transparent c'est ces gens rient
son bac et par qui ils sont financés
comment est ce que tu t'es renseigne sur
sa vie ils ont été la position de
l'ambassade américaine sur place comment
ça se passe
alors les américains ça c'était l'autre
truc intéressant mais les américains et
ils préféraient ne pas ne pas se
retrouver dans une histoire où il ya des
néo nazis
j'en doute pas une seconde il préférait
de la révolution orange avec des gens
présentable que d'avoir à zob epr avis
hector dans le bouillon sauf que la
tendance lourde du département d'état
étant de stimuler les révolutions de en
moins de faire de ce qu'on appelle du
containment de la russie oui en fait on
n'a pas perdu alors déjà dans mon compte
elle même c'est à dire qu en français
contention contention qu'on se contenir
tu vois c'est l'idée de contenir mais au
sens pro active du terme est vrai j'aime
bien les compétitions mais dans la prise
de contrôle de la dialectique sait
contenir ou c'est freiner ou sait
contenir contre quoi une invasion russe
et c'est pour ça que j'aime bien
contention parce que
une bande de contention c'est non
seulement le soutien mais c'est ce qui
te pousse qui te dire et c'est bon c'est
vrai que pour ça un secret pour personne
que il ya l'otan tout autour de tout
autour de la russie donc il ya depuis la
chute de l'union soviétique il ya eu une
sorte de poursuite de la logique de du
côté des américains en tout cas de
grignoter ou de contenir plutôt de
contenir de noter c'est pas le bon mais
de contenir l'espace de l'empiré russe
qu'est ce qui se passe quand on est en
bas de contention comme tu dis est trop
serré il se passe c'est pas ce qui s'est
passé en ukraine c'est parce qu'il s'est
passé en ukraine
je pense qu'effectivement il fait pas
tellement de doute que les russes sont
très actifs dans le donbass
pourquoi ils sont très actifs parce que
c'est un ses démarches de chez eux deux
il ya beaucoup de russes
et quand même énormément de russes qui
sont denses et peu dans cette zone là de
russophones des gens d'origine russe qui
se sentent menacés par l'ultra
nationalisme ukrainien après il ya des
raisons objectives à ça mais les russes
ils ont un comment ils ont un intérêt
géostratégique évident à créer une zone
d'une sorte de zone tampon à favoriser
une zone tampon dans la dans l'est dans
l'est de l'ukraine
et c'est évident qu'il le favorise le
degré d'engagement des russes il ya des
versions diverses mais c'est évident
qu'ils sont là c'est évident que c'est
leur intérêt mais
un intérêt pour envahi ou un intérêt
pour résister non moi je pense que si
les russes si les russes vous le schéma
un peu mécanique et brutale les russes
veulent envahir le cren il en a pour
quelques heures
c
si c'était ça le leurs projets non les
russes veulent à mon sens mais c'est une
analyse parce que je suis en train de te
parler d'un truc que j'ai pas enquêté
est ce que j'aime pas énormément
j'ai beaucoup enquêté sur sur l'est les
milices d'extrême droite ukrainienne et
leur utilisation comme supplétifs par
par le pouvoir ukrainien et une partie
du département d'état américain qui
préfère ne pas s'intéresser trop à qui
sont de fait les alliés sur le terrain
parce que c'est c'est de ça qu'il s'agit
tu remarqueras que le département d'état
américain les gens que tu vois sur place
et c'est bon dorian yolande c'est
vraiment le courant néo con tu vois pas
énormément qui rit tu vois mccain pour
pouvoir la frime
ouais à chaque fois à chaque fois qu'il
passe quelque part ça crame well études
tu vois mccain et tu vois newland c'est
une sorte de point c'est un courant quel
courant néo-conservateur eux ils
préfèrent s'appelait maintenant ils ont
changé de nom et s'appelle libéral
interventionniste libéral interview
exactement la même chose
donc j'ai pas j'ai pas enquêté
profondément sur sur les intentions des
russes mais bon voilà allez les jaune
clair qu'ils ont des intérêts évidents à
ce que le dombass reste une zone tampon
entre et et l'ukraine
les journalistes français est ta
perception sur comment la presse
française a perçu ton document enquêter
contre enquête et est ce que les réseaux
ukrainiens ton diplomate a fait de la
merde ton truc on peut te le des
bouquets dont reprendre l'expression
consacrée
et est ce qu il yad autres jours indiqué
soraya ta cause ou est ce qu'ils ont
fait un petit peu de lui dans le sur
leurs chaussures sièges sont dit oulala
c'est tellement chaud que bon on va
peut-être pour y toucher
qu'est ce qui s'est passé écoute le
groupe parce qu'il ya un petit groupe
qui s'est manifesté quel groupe c'est un
groupe de jeunes journalistes qui comme
enfin commencé leur carrière en ukraine
dont c'est la première guerre qui se
connaissent bien il ya le benoît vitkine
qui travaillent qui a couvert le conflit
pour pour le monde
il ya un garçon qui s'appelle stéphane
siohan qui a couvert pour le figaro et
en gros quelques copains autour de ces
des gens que j'ai rencontrés à kiev que
j'ai croisé avec qui on a échangé
quelques mots dont j'ai su par mes
contacts en ukraine les gens avec qui je
travaillais qui savait qu'il s'était
senti humilié par mon film cdc le je
comprenais pas pourquoi pourquoi ça me
revenait quoi pourquoi humilier
je ne parle absolument pas du traitement
de la firme craignent par les médias
français à aucun moment je ne cite pas
le mot quoi mais je crois que font de la
faire c'est ça c'est à dire que je passe
la moitié de documentaires parlé de
massacre de dessins pour la plupart
d'entre eux sont pas écrit une ligne
dessus pas une ligne
un gars comme stéphane six ans qui a été
le plus agressif à mon égard quel donc
multiplient jce mais qui travaille
notamment pour le figaro il avait fait
pour elle un portrait d'une combattante
ukrainienne nationaliste ukrainienne le
titre le titre du portrait et très
belles photos d'une jolie blonde comme
ça avec une arme en uniforme c'était une
guerre si particulière un truc un peu
adolescents romantique
en fait en compterons qu'étant on s'est
aperçu qu'elle faisait partie d'un
groupe néo-nazi son site sa page
facebook elle appelait au génocide et du
coup elle avait été obligé de s'excuser
de aux numéros suivants de dire on
savait pas qu'elle était nazi mais si on
devait le savoir qu'elle était nazi
alors le truc amusant c'est que quand je
vends cette idée l'idée de ce film à à
canal+
si on fait toujours un petit dossier
pour leur dire c'est une histoire
intéressante et la photo que je met en
couverture
c'est précisément l'histoire de ce
scandale créé par stéphane sirot dans le
dans l'histoire de l dans le portrait de
la néo nazis non identifiés comme néo
nazis et donc genre explique c'est
intéressant parce que voilà on a une
perception naturel qui est dire ils sont
formidables
les nationalistes ukrainiens ils sont
tellement joli sens tellement
sympathique y sont tellement bleues mais
en vérité il ya une sorte de paresse
intellectuelle qui empêche de d'aller un
peu plus loin que le que dès que la
fable qu'on nous sert et stéphane durand
c'est sûrement un journaliste correct je
dis pas le contraire mais lui-même se
fait avoir quoi il fait un portrait
magnifique du néo nazis en dissimulant
veut dissimuler je sais pas peut-être
que le savez pas j'en sais rien mais en
tout cas en omettant d'enquêter sur qui
est cette personne oblige elle est un
grand journal français a présenté des
excuses pour avoir fait la promotion du
néo nazis la semaine suivante tout en
alors enfin je le lis to fall l'histoire
dans l'histoire c'est que quand même il
se rend dans une région dont il sait
parfaitement que le groupe auquel
appartient cette jeune femme que le
bataillon haidar se rend coupable des
actions puisque deux semaines auparavant
amnesty international avait sorti un
rapport là dessus dix ans autour de
lougansk est l'endroit où il est allé il
ya des exactions commises par ce
bataillon donc au minimum tu poses la
question au minimum tu prends une petite
distance et puis tu fais attention quoi
donc voilà je j'ai effectivement j'avais
utilisé cette espèce de
de preuve spectaculaire d'une sorte de
paresse intellectuelle qui faisait voir
les choses en blanc et noir pour vendre
mon est-ce que c'est généralisé est ce
que c'est généraliser la paresse
intellectuelle chez les gens en lice
quand vous gagnez votre profession est
ce que c'est pour ça que sur internet
c'est compliqué à des deux journalistes
donc nous chez nous on vous aime pas
clairement ouais je sais vous aime pas
et c'est compliqué de dire vous les
journalistes tu vois c'est comme dire à
l'intérieur une perte collatéral ouais
moi je me méfie toujours de dire vous
laissez moi je connais plein de
journalistes qui sont dans leur zone en
feu
tu vois effectivement reproduisant en
fait le plus grand danger du journalisme
c'est le panurgisme c1 panurgisme ouais
ouais
c2c de la pensée groupe c
et là moi je me suis retrouvé face à un
exemple de pensée de groupe sur le cren
honnêtement pas de gens je pourrai pas
les vexer mais pas de gens très
brillants pas de gens que je respecte
énormément des gens de la plupart
d'entre eux ne connaissaient pas leur
nom quoi j'avais jamais rien lu 2 mai
enfin voila mais il faut se méfier de la
pensée de groupe que ce soit la pensée
de groupe à coeur la pensée de groupe
conspi la pensée de groupe
tu as connu en alsace groupe à coeur 1
tu la connais la pour ce groupe car là
du tout ça c'est la salle pour 5 heures
on vous aide nous on vous aime pas vu je
me dis bah c'est une pensée de groupe
dont il faut se méfier
d'accord nous on essaye de faire vivre
quand même toutes les idées on s'est
intéressé à ton dossier parce que on est
quand même ouvert surtout dans sa chose
et que
on prend pas comme argent comptant tout
ce qu'on nous raconte qu'on débat entre
nous c'est pour ça qu'on a créé aussi
cette chaîne youtube parce que on avait
besoin aussi de vous prendre sur votre
terrain vous attrapez un port a pas
faire un concours de [__] de neurones
mais on a aussi nos réseaux de terrain
on a aussi notre expérience de terrain
et quand on voit des journalistes nous
expliquer leur vérité des fois ça pique
maintenant on commence à en avoir un
c'est donc on va vous cherchez un tel
réseau oui on se débrouille pour avoir
vos numéros de téléphone on se
débrouille pour prendre un hôtel votre
salle de réception vous êtes assistant
je pense qu'on fera une émission
ensemble et je voudrais qu'on passe à la
dernière partie de notre émission qui
est les conseils pour les jeunes
générations
est-ce que tu as un conseil pour les
jeunes générations sur la lecture
géopolitique des choses comment tu vois
la géopolitique à cinq ans comment tu
vois la france à cinq ans un conseil
pour les jeunes journalistes
les jeunes générations c'est une
bouteille à la mer c'est une bouteille à
la mer on va te rendre immortel
aujourd'hui grâce à la nsa ou et aux
serveurs de google
tu es immortel profites en
écoute conseille aux jeunes générations
de journalistes ou de préconisation
allez savoir dur à je pense que les aux
jeunes journalistes je dirais je
voudrais d'abord les remercier de choix
parce que c'est souvent des jeunes gens
intelligents payer avec un lance pierre
voilà et de choisir un métier où ils
vont être assez misérable sauf pour
quelques uns d'entre eux où ils vont ont
réussi à moi je suis toujours surpris de
devoir d'aider des types qui sont prêts
à abandonner énormément de confort
matériel pour en gros pour détendre le
monde pour dix ans la moitié d'entre eux
quoi et donc je vais leur dire que si
c'est pas pour détendre le monde qui
font ce boulot là bas qu'il fasse autre
chose qui fasse un truc qui fasse un
truc un truc utile quoi quand on parle
quand on parle de vous sur notre
communauté on a souvent des gens qui
débarquent ils nous disent voilà
journalistes c'est soit put soient
chômeurs ouais c'est violent écoute ou
soit viré moi j'aime j'ai été j'ai été
choisi comme pour faire le discours
inaugural compagne augurale comment
s'appelait ce truc là
à la fin de l'année d'une école de
journalisme s'appelait site et le lac
aux journalistes de paris jeu j'étais
jeu prononcé un discours il m'avait
choisi m'avez élu pour prononcer un
discours avant qu'il rentre dans la vie
active et donc j'avais fait un discours
qui s'appelait éloge du licenciement
parce que si tu fais ce métier en te
disant que tu vas t'asseoir sur une
chaise tu vas t'y vis et tu vas tenir
coûte que coûte parce que c'est un cdi
parce que c'est important c'est
important d'avoir du fric à sion puis
sur lie pas mais c'est pas un métier
qu'il faut faire en se disant je vais
m'accrocher coûte que coûte faut être
prêt à se faire virer
c'est un suicide social ce poids suicide
social c'est quand même vachement
sympathique d'être journaliste n'aurait
suicide social
non non faut pas exagérer on est quand
même en on a quand même du bol quoi toi
c'est enfin moi j'étais maçon j'ai été
coursier
était chauffeur livreur j'étais ouvrier
dans une imprimerie je peux dire que ça
s'est déboîté boulot dur journalistes
c'est quand même tu as réussi à trouver
n'y gâche pour faire un truc rigolo en
étant payé pourquoi faut pas toi la
souffrance de regarder la montre vers 9h
9h15 et de se dire merde je croyais
qu'il était 11 heures
je sais ce que c'est c'est pas
journaliste quoi donc on est là donc
quand on a la chance de faire un boulot
comme ça
quels qu'ils soient il n'y a pas que
journaliste pour remercier le sort
quelque chose à rajouter parce que tu as
des questions à nous poser
oui moi je sais pas qui vous êtes ne
veut pas dire et alors non mais sur ça
sympa enfin j'ai vu j'ai accepté cette
interview parce que j'ai vu ce que vous
avez fait avant je trouve ça car et je
trouve ça très bien
je trouve ça très bien d'aller à la
rencontre de gens qui sont pas dans son
schéma de pensée et qui vont poser les
questions autrement
qui de toute évidence ont un disque dur
assez fourni assez nourris et qui vont
tu vois qu'ils vont cet entretien
ressemblent pas forcément celui que
j'aurai avec avec un journaliste scott
que de toute évidence vous avez un
disque dur assez assez plein quand même
temps vous avez une manière de poser les
questions qui à la fois je trouve
j'apprécie vous vérifié j'ai
l'impression de soumettre à une sorte de
travail de vérification parce que toi
dérogatoire sur certains points temps
c'est autant que moi est une sorte de
travail de vérification parfois donc
c'est un peu déstabilisant c'est un peu
inconfortable mais je crois qu'il faut
le faire c'est bien paul moreira
merci de rien
[Musique]
e
à
le
[Musique]